J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez.
Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Salut tout le monde et bonne année. J'espère que deux mille vingt-trois vous apportera beaucoup de bonheur et plein de belles rencontres.
Moi, j'y compte bien. Plein de projets cool dans mes escarcelles et un cortège de personnes incroyables à rencontrer.
Je sais pas encore lesquelles, mais ça se prépare. Et pour bien commencer l'année, une voix et un visage connus puisque Myriam revient pour la troisième fois dans Septante Minutes Avec.
Pour rappel, Myriam Leroy est la seule qui a le droit de revenir. Et cette fois-ci, c'est pour parler de son nouveau roman,
des thèmes qu'elle y aborde, du travail de préparation qui a entouré ce roman et évidemment du prisme féministe dont elle se sert pour raconter l'histoire de son héroïne, Marina Tcharoff.
On raconte tout ça. Le roman s'appelle Le Mystère de la femme sans tête. C'est parti.
Dernière fois que tu es venue, on s'était quittés justement sur plein de teasing de tes futurs projets, de tes balades au cimetière d'Ixelles et tout ça.
Donc, tu as, tu as déjà raconté en fait le—
Ah oui.
La prémisse.
J'ai plus rien à dire.
Mais on peut rappeler aux gens. Salut Myriam.
Salut.
Donc on se voit parce que tu sors un nouveau roman, Le Mystère de la femme sans tête.
Et donc, comme je viens de l'annoncer rapidement, ça t'est venu parce que tu t'es promenée au cimetière d'Ixelles avec Amèle et que tu es tombée sur une pierre tombale très mystérieuse.
Avec Amélie.
Amélie ?
C'est presque la même chose, mais il y a deux lettres qui changent et puis c'est pas la même personne.
C'est pas la même personne. Ok, j'ai tout mélangé.
Et là, tu veux que je te raconte la suite, c'est ça ?
Dis-moi, dis-moi tout ce que tu as à me dire. Ça s'est passé quand ? C'était en plein COVID, du coup.
Oui, c'était au début du deuxième confinement. Enfin, en tout cas, en plein dans le deuxième confinement. Et à cette époque, on n'avait pas le droit de se voir les uns chez les autres.
Les cafés, les bars étaient fermés. Et quand on se baladait dans la rue, qui était l'endroit où généralement on se retrouvait, hein, il y a eu une mode de la promenade entre amis.
Je sais pas si toi, t'y as cédé. Moi, un petit peu. Puis ça a ensuite rentré dans l'ordre. Mais voilà, donc c'était—
je voulais me promener avec une amie et je voulais me promener sans masque parce qu'on avait envie de discuter à bâtons rompus.
Et comme la police patrouillait vachement dans les rues à l'époque, eh ben, je me suis dit : « Ah ben tiens, si on allait au cimetière d'Ixelles, la police n'ira quand même pas verbaliser les gens au cimetière.
» Et en effet, les polices ne rentrent pas au cimetière. Donc c'est un conseil que je vous donne si jamais vous avez envie d'enfreindre les règles du COVID des prochains confinements qui risquent de se reproduire.
T'aimes pas, tu me regardes en me jugeant.
Non, je te regarde avec attention.
Et voilà, après quelques secondes, on a eu le regard attiré par le carré des martyrs de la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Et Amélie, qui est prof, enfin institutrice primaire et maternelle, elle s'amusait de voir que tous les hommes enterrés là, parce qu'il y avait que des hommes,
portaient des prénoms que les gamins de sa classe portaient, donc qui avaient un retour en grâce.
Toutes tes amies sont soit prof, soit travaillent avec des enfants.
Prof, ouais, ouais, ouais, c'est vrai. D'ailleurs, j'écris une série sur l'enseignement. J'exploite mes amis profs et je les trahis.
Je trahis leur histoire.
Tu tires profit.
Je m'abreuve à leur mamelle. Oui, bien sûr. Et donc oui, tous les gamins dans sa classe s'appellent Maurice, Lucien.
Oui, une pléiade, du coup.
Voilà, c'est ça. Et donc on faisait le tour. C'est parce qu'elle travaille dans une école un petit peu bobo.
Et dans cet océan d'hommes tous fusillés, il y avait une femme, Marina, et un motif de la mort différent de celui de ses coreligionnaires, puisque sous son nom, il était indiqué décapité.
Donc, sur le moment, on a fait une photo de la pierre tombale, on a ri un peu nerveusement, mais ça nous a quand même bien glacées.
Et puis quand je suis rentrée chez moi, j'ai posté la photo sur Instagram. Et là, il y a quelqu'un qui m'a dit que c'était dommage qu'il y avait peu de choses sur elle sur Internet.
Et je me dis : « Bon ben, s'il y a peu de choses, ça veut dire qu'il y a quand même quelque chose. » Et en effet, il y avait un article de blog en espagnol et,
une vidéo YouTube d'une sorte de conférence en distanciel organisée par le Centre culturel russe de Bruxelles qui venait de se produire et où on parlait d'elle comme étant la Jeanne d'Arc belge.
Et je me disais : « Mais enfin, je dois vraiment être peu instruite sur l'histoire belge », parce que je n'avais jamais entendu parler de cette femme.
Ce nom ne me disait absolument rien, Marina Tcharoff. Et puis j'ai regardé le visage de cette Marina, puisque son visage est— tu peux le voir sur Google Images. Et—
C'est une photo avant sa mise à mort, du coup ?
Ouais, c'est ça.
Et une autre photo où elle est un peu plus souriante.
Oui, une photo où elle est plus jeune, je pense, que la photo où elle souriante, elle est même adolescente.
Mais comme elle a un visage très enfantin, même à l'heure de la mort, quand elle avait trente-trois ans, c'est difficile, difficile de la dater.
C'est difficile de lui donner un âge et c'est difficile de la situer dans une époque aussi, parce que je trouve qu'elle a un physique très, très contemporain.
Et tout ça, plus son regard fondeur, plus la cruauté de sa mise à mort, puisque je découvre qu'elle avait été décapitée, non seulement décapitée, mais aussi décapitée à la hache, ce qui n'est pas rien.
Oui, ce qui est réservé, c'est quoi ? C'est aux nobles, c'est ça ?
Oui, c'est ce que j'ai entendu. Aux nobles et donc, par extension, aux femmes. C'est une sorte de galanterie, hein.
C'est ça, voilà.
Le petit cadeau qu'on leur faisait manifestement. Mais si quelqu'un a d'autres explications, ça m'intéresserait. C'est la seule que j'ai trouvée jusqu'ici.
Mais c'est difficile d'avoir des infos là-dessus. C'est difficile, notamment parce que la décapitation était interdite, mais...
Au sein du Troisième Reich. Mais les nazis la pratiquaient quand même, mais en la dévoyant un peu à la hache quoi.
On va revenir là-dessus, mais je trouve, ouais, c'est une démarche particulière parce que c'est à la fois un roman et en même temps un travail journalistique, un travail d'enquête, un travail d'historien presque de,
voilà, confronter les sources, confronter les différents documents.
Ouais.
Et donc là, tu donnes un premier exemple de : mais what the fuck ? Comment c'est possible ? Et pas vraiment de réponse.
Non. Il y a énormément de—
On va le voir souvent, je pense.
Oui.
Donc voilà, ça pose la question de voir qu'elle avait été décapitée à la hache. Et qu'est-ce qui a déclenché cet intérêt spécifique pour cette—
Cette obsession, tu veux dire ?
Ben bon alors, le mot décapité, très clairement. Je crois que le voir inscrit comme ça sur une pierre, dans un cimetière, le fait que ce soit une femme, donc c'est une double anomalie et c'est une double violence en fait.
Donc clairement, ça, ça pique la curiosité. Son visage, comme je te disais, m'a vraiment fait quelque chose.
C'est-à-dire ?
Elle a un côté très frondeur et elle a une espèce de morgue où elle s'excuse pas d'exister. C'est pas le visage d'une femme polie, avenante, bien élevée, gentiment peignée.
Enfin, il y a un truc très moderne en fait, dans une forme de rage qu'elle exprime dans son regard. Alors ça, forcément—
Il y a deux photos dont—
Des photos qui sont disponibles sur Google Images.
T'as lu tout ça sur ces deux photos. Une forme de rage, une forme de modernité.
En tout cas, j'en ai déduit ça. C'est mon intuition. Maintenant, évidemment qu'elle avait une forme de rage vu qu'elle allait bientôt être décapitée.
Donc c'est clairement pas le genre de situation où tu as un visage détendu, serein et avenant. Mais
ouais, c'était intéressant de voir son côté très— ouais, son côté très moderne faisait tout à coup,
enfin physiquement, je veux dire, faisait tout à coup prendre vie à un pan du passé qui pour moi, et pour toi certainement plus encore, a toujours été en noir et blanc et donc très mis à distance, très—
presque de l'ordre de la fiction quoi.
C'était une drôle d'époque qui n'est plus. Et tout à coup, cette époque était à nouveau, grâce à cette photo, sous mes yeux.
C'est ça. Donc t'as un peu tissé un lien avec cette personne via donc cette rencontre dans le cimetière, via cette photo, alors que c'était jusqu'à présent une époque—
Qui m'intéressait pas tellement.
Qui t'intéressait pas et qui semblait complètement révolue, enfin avec laquelle tu n'avais pas de contact.
Aucun.
Et là, tout d'un coup, cette personne en particulier, du fait de son sort hors norme, t'as eu, je sais pas, j'ai l'impression, une forme d'empathie très forte, une forme de...
Oui, oui, mais puis une forme d'envie aussi. Parce que dès que j'ai vu, même avant de savoir qui elle était et ce qu'on lui a reproché, la raison pour laquelle on lui a coupé la tête,
je me suis dit : mais si on l'a décapitée, c'est qu'elle a dû faire quelque chose de— elle a dû commettre une énorme transgression, elle a dû se rebeller contre l'ordre établi, elle a dû faire un truc gore.
Je sais pas, je savais pas ce que c'était, mais ça devait être énorme, ça devait être spectaculaire. Donc il y avait un truc là, rien qu'en lisant le mot décapité, il y avait tout un uni— enfin, c'était une fenêtre sur un imaginaire,
de guerrière en fait, d'amazone qui s'ouvrait.
Et à ce moment-là de ma vie,
je me sentais pas très guerrière, pas très amazone. Déjà comme tout le monde pendant le confinement, je crois qu'on se sentait quand même relativement— qu'on soit d'accord ou pas avec les,
les règles fluctuantes de nos autorités, on était quand même tous— on avait le sentiment de tous être un peu passifs et d'attendre quelle allait être la prochaine décision, qu'est-ce qu'on allait pouvoir refaire.
Restreindre vos possibilités.
Oui, c'est ça.
Contraintes.
Et donc je me sentais vachement, vachement passive comme tout le monde, mais je me sentais aussi passive parce que je venais de perdre un procès et je trouvais ça absolument injuste et j'en attendais un autre.
Et ça me contraignait aussi au silence, puisque il est recommandé de ne pas, voilà, dévoiler d'éléments de procédure, etc.
Donc c'était vraiment un moment de grand silence et de grand repli en fait. Et là, je me disais : mais cette nana, elle a dû commettre un truc qui est le contraire du silence, qui est le contraire du repli.
Donc oui, c'est ça, c'est sans doute ça qui a enclenché le mécanisme qui a fait qu'à un moment donné, je n'ai plus fait que penser à elle et à travailler sur elle.
Ouais, et on verra dans la suite de l'histoire, mais pas mal de coïncidences, pas mal de rencontres qui se produisent exactement au bon moment.
Et donc là, ça semblait répondre chez toi à une frustration, une rancœur par rapport à ta situation, par rapport aux hommes qui étaient sur ton chemin.
Et t'as vu, donc on ne l'a toujours pas dit, donc cette personne qui a, Marina, qui a donc poignardé ou qui aurait poignardé, qui a été accusée de poignarder.
En tout cas, qui a endossé la responsabilité d'un attentat au couteau contre un officier, enfin un fonctionnaire allemand, porte de Namur à Bruxelles.
Donc on dit qu'elle est sortie de chez elle un jour de décembre 1941 avec un couteau à la main et puis qu'elle a remonté la chaussée d'Ixelles et qu'elle est arrivée porte de Namur, là où il y avait le mess, la cantine des nazis.
Elle en a poignardé un et elle s'est enfuie en courant. Puis elle a pris un tram pour rentrer chez elle, pour faire cette courte distance.
Et dès le lendemain, la presse faisait écho de cet attentat et publiait des avis des Allemands disant que si le coupable ne se rendait pas, soixante otages allaient être fusillés.
C'est beaucoup.
Oui, c'est beaucoup. Ouais. Alors qu'en plus, il y avait la loi Nacht und..., je ne sais plus comment on dit en allemand, mais c'est nuit et brouillard en français.
C'est un décret qui en fait donnait le prix à payer si on décidait de commettre un attentat. C'est-à-dire que si tu tuais un nazi, ben alors on fusillait cinq personnes.
Si tu blessais un nazi, une seule. Mais là, tout à coup, ça devenait soixante personnes. Donc c'est vraiment très bizarre.
C'était pas conforme au règlement qui est entré en vigueur pile le jour de l'attentat en fait.
La différence, c'est peut-être que là, l'auteur ou l'autrice de l'attentat était inconnu. Et donc il y avait peut-être plus de pression parce qu'on voulait forcer le—
Oui, oui, bien sûr. Je pense qu'il y a énormément de propagande et de communication là-derrière. D'ailleurs, est-ce que ces soixante otages ont vraiment existé ?
Je n'en suis même pas sûre. Je les ai beaucoup cherchés et personne, pendant deux ans, j'ai voulu lancer des appels à témoins un peu partout.
Je n'en suis même pas sûre. Personne ne s'est manifesté. Mais enfin, soit. Et donc Marina, ça, c'est vrai et c'est sûr.
Une semaine après l'attentat, elle s'est rendue aux Allemands en disant : Bah voilà, c'est moi que vous cherchez. Et tant qu'à faire, j'endosse la responsabilité de tous les attentats qui ont été commis un peu partout dans le monde.
Voilà, vous pouvez tout mettre sur ma tronche. Puis elle a été jugée et puis déportée en Allemagne. Et puis en janvier 1942, elle a eu la tête coupée, donc à la hache.
Voilà. Ça, c'est la version officielle. Il y a d'autres versions. Enfin, il y a la version soviétique, puisque Marina Tcharoff était d'origine russe.
Donc les Soviétiques, pendant longtemps, ont été assez fiers de cet attentat. Et ils estimaient— enfin, voilà, ils présentaient Marina comme étant une authentique bolchévique, une rouge, rouge sang.
L'agent d'influence de l'époque.
Voilà, c'est ça. Alors que bon, elle était pas, enfin, elle était russe blanche, Marina. Ça veut dire que par opposition aux Russes rouges, ça veut dire qu'elle venait de, elle était d'ascendance noble, tsariste.
Et a priori, dans cette communauté-là, on ne se rebellait pas vraiment contre l'occupant sur certains points. En tout cas, pour certains, on était plutôt alignés.
Voilà, en fait, Marina, c'est une anomalie de A à Z et c'est une anomalie assez grandiose qu'on a oubliée. Et c'est le projet de mon roman, c'est de—
plus que de reconstituer ce qui s'est réellement produit, qui était réellement cette femme, c'est de savoir pourquoi elle a été oubliée.
Contextualiser cette anomalie de—
Ouais, c'est ça.
Comment c'est possible.
Ouais.
Ouais. L'autre— donc on va se pencher là-dessus juste après. Mais l'autre truc qui est savoureux, quand on le lit, c'est évidemment quand on est Bruxellois, quand on est Ixellois et qu'on voit les adresses,
bah, chaussée d'Ixelles,
l'avenue Louise et compagnie et tout ça, c'est très,
c'est très bluffant de se sentir— et puis le début de ton histoire, c'est une belle Ixelles, se dire que tout ça prend pied vraiment, bah pour nous, c'est vraiment, c'est en bas de chez nous quoi.
Oui, oui. Oui, c'est des quartiers qu'en plus, même si on n'y vit pas. Alors en l'occurrence, nous, on y vit. Mais
tout le monde connaît la porte de Namur parce que c'est— tout le monde y passe en voiture ou a un jour été faire une course là-bas, a dû faire réparer un ordinateur, j'en sais rien, mais c'est un quartier commerçant.
Ouais.
C'est un quartier dédié, ouais, c'est ça, au capitalisme triomphant. Et c'est marrant. Enfin, c'est fou d'imaginer que ces trottoirs-là ont été foulés par des personnes qui vivaient une réalité tellement différente de la nôtre.
Et moi, ça, je trouvais ça vertigineux, en fait. Mais peut-être que je découvrais l'eau tiède, j'en sais rien, mais je me dis— c'était fou pour moi.
Je sais que ça va l'air idiot, de me rendre compte que l'histoire avait réellement existé.
Mais je vois ce que tu veux dire. Enfin, de mesurer l'histoire dans ces bâtiments, quand on se balade, chaussée d'Ixelles, en fait, c'est pas juste.
Ce centre commercial, ce Vanden Borre n'a pas toujours été là.
Exactement.
Il y a eu des trucs sordides par le passé.
Oui, et la commandante tueure en face de laquelle elle a commis son, enfin, elle aurait commis son crime.
Ça a été un bâtiment d'Electrabel après. Enfin voilà, en fait, les choses sont devenues beaucoup plus apaisées.
Donc c'est chouette, mais c'est devenu quand même beaucoup plus plat aussi en matière de dramaturgie.
Clairement, clairement, clairement. Et donc, un personnage d'exception, d'après ce que tu expliques, dans un contexte où on se demande : mais comment c'est possible ?
Et toi, tu arrives avec plusieurs pistes. Donc,
alors déjà, ce qui est particulier et ce qui m'a très fort surpris en lisant le livre, c'est que moi, je m'attendais, parce que tu m'avais parlé de ce projet
avant de le publier, je m'attendais donc à un roman, une partie de fiction, une partie de réalité, une essaie de retracer son chemin.
Mais en fait, tu fais plus que ça, puisque tu retraces, tu parles de toi. Tu parles de toi à la deuxième personne.
Ouais.
Qu'est-ce qui explique ce choix-là de
recontextualiser non seulement l'histoire du personnage, mais de parler de toi et de ce que tu ressentais à ce moment-là, des rencontres que tu as pu faire en travaillant sur le--
qu'est-ce qui t'a donné envie de mélanger le sujet et l'enquête ?
Il y a toute une série de raisons, mais je pense que la principale, c'est de toujours montrer d'où je parle et d'où je façonne le personnage.
C'est une sorte de...
D'humilité ?
Non, non, de... Je montre pas juste la peinture, je montre l'angle de la peinture, comment j'ai mis le chevalet, enfin les coulisses de la création du personnage.
Puisque comme c'est un personnage à propos duquel j'ai dû inventer beaucoup, pas les faits, pas les citations, pas les articles de journaux, pas les lettres, tout ça, c'est réel.
Mais j'ai dû inventer quand même ces--
La psychologie.
Ça, oui, oui, sa psych-- enfin, je l'ai déduite, sa psychologie, des lettres que j'avais lues et des articles de journaux que j'avais lus, qui la citaient aussi, qui citaient certains de ses emportements, notamment au tribunal. Mais
ces déplacements dans la ville,
en fait, pour examiner la naissance de cet ouragan,
parce qu'à un moment donné, je me suis dit que le livre pouvait peut-être s'appeler Naissance d'un ouragan, parce que je crois que c'est ça qui-- enfin, que c'est un livre sur une tempête quoi.
Puis Geoffrey Clemca t'a susurré un titre beaucoup plus vendeur.
Le mystère de la femme sans tête. Oui, oui, c'est ça. Beaucoup plus, oui, beaucoup plus concret. Parce que j'avais proposé Naissance des ouragans à mon éditrice et elle a dit : Ah bon ?
Bof. Bon voilà. Alors que j'étais sûre que c'était un titre de génie. Enfin voilà, comment on-- d'où naît une révolte ? Ben ça,
moi, je connais, je sais vous expliquer que la mienne,
mais je pense que tout est extrapolable et je pense qu'il y a des liens à faire entre les humains d'aujourd'hui et les humains d'autrefois, et puis les femmes d'aujourd'hui et les femmes d'autrefois, et
la manière dont on entre en résistance et en rébellion aujourd'hui et autrefois.
Et je pense que, ben qui veux-tu que j'intègre d'autres dans le dispositif que moi, puisque je me mets ce, je mets sous les yeux.
Je mets sous les yeux ? Ah oui, oui, tout à fait. Ça fait pas très français, mais magnifiquement installé. Voilà. Non, mais il y a aussi l'idée de montrer les-- le livre montre le livre en train de s'écrire.
C'est ça.
Donc une sorte de making of à post-- Permanent, même s'il est pas-- enfin qu'il vient en contrepoint, s'il est pas permanent dans le sens où il prend pas un volume énorme dans le livre, mais j'y reviens souvent.
Sans le doute, l'hésitation.
Oui.
Le j'aimerais bien écrire ça, mais je suis pas sûr.
Ouais.
Et telle personne m'a dit ceci et donc, j'hésite un peu, mais je recommande de voir comme ça.
Oui, de dire aussi ce n'est que moi, ce sont mes biais.
C'est pour ça que j'ai dit humilité.
J'écris de quelque part.
Ah oui.
Voilà, mais ce sont mes intuitions, j'ai pas de certitude à vous présenter à part celle où je vous dis que vous-- enfin voilà, où je vous présente des documents et là c'est réel.
C'est ça.
C'est la vérité.
Et donc tu parlais de parallèle. Ce qui m'a encore plus surpris, c'est quand tu commences à évoquer par exemple tes mauvaises expériences dans les rédactions journalistiques en Belgique.
Je me disais, mais c'est pas possible. Elle m'avait dit il y a un an qu'elle voulait tourner la page, ne plus parler de harcèlement tout ça et,
et je m'attendais justement à lire quelque chose qui part, mais à trois cents kilomètres de là, remonter quatre-vingts années en arrière.
Et en fait, tu reviens là-dessus.
Bah oui, parce que je part-- c'était ma situation à cette époque.
À l'époque.
Donc en plus j'ai l'impression que le livre, enfin, ce projet nécessitait que-- enfin, il y avait quand même un contrat avec le réel plus fort.
Enfin évidemment beaucoup plus fort que mes livres précédents qui étaient de l'autofiction. Ici, c'est pas de l'autofiction.
Enfin, en tout cas les parties qui parlent de moi de manière contemporaine, c'est autobiographique quoi.
Clairement, ouais.
Donc il y a pas de fiction là-dedans, mais je pense que pour que les gens acceptent de me suivre dans ce que je vais leur raconter,
il faut qu'ils comprennent qu'il y a une honnêteté quoi dans ce que je dis, même s'il y a une manière d'inventer et de combler des blancs avec de l'imagination.
Il y a de l'honnêteté et il y a de la rigueur. Je comble les blancs, mais pas à partir de rien ou d'une usine qui me, enfin voilà, une idée qui m'aurait juste traversé comme ça par hasard.
Et donc ça m'obligeait quelque part à être-- à coller particulièrement au réel quand je parlais de moi.
Oui. Et donc ce parallèle que tu essayes de faire avec le personnage, où est-ce que tu le situes exactement ?
À quel moment est-ce que vos chemins se rejoignent ? Qu'est-ce qui est similaire chez elle et toi ? Parce qu'on-- moi, j'ai vu des trucs, mais je suis pas certain que c'était assumé, désiré.
Donc je suis curieux d'avoir ta réponse.
Mais en fait, je pense que ce que j'ai essayé de faire, c'était de montrer que c'était pas juste elle et moi.
Mmm-hmm.
La relation, qu'on était toutes en relation.
D'accord, oui.
Et que la-- enfin, il y a une phrase qui dit dans le bouquin que le seul point commun que je vois entre les femmes, c'est qu'on est traité comme des femmes.
Et ça j'en suis sûre. Je suis sûre que ce point commun entre nous existe. Maintenant pour le reste, non. Là où il y a un dialogue en fait, entre elle et moi.
Je superpose nos silhouettes, mais je ne les confonds pas. Je n'ai pas le même vécu qu'elle. Par exemple, elle était extrêmement pieuse.
Moi, c'est vraiment pas du tout. Elle était, bah, c'était une mère de famille. Moi pas du tout. Elle avait des préoccupations qui n'étaient pas du tout les miennes, mais en tout cas, je pense que sur les questions de
de frus-, de petites frustrations ordinaires quotidiennes, là, je pense qu'on a des-- certainement des vécus, elle et moi, mais tout le monde, toutes les femmes du monde qui se parlent.
Mais plus pr-, ouais, donc je rejoins tout à fait. Je comprends tout à fait ce que tu expliques sur le fait d'être perçu, considéré, abordé comme femme et tout ce que ça peut rejoindre comme expérience.
Mais plus précisément,
le profil que tu dépeins dans le livre, c'est un profil idéaliste, romantique un peu aussi, quelqu'un de très émotive qui peut avoir une crise de rage quand elle voit son mari faire des trucs qui lui plaisent pas.
Des pleurs, très douce avec les animaux. T'expliques à un moment donné qu'elle sauve les guêpes qui se noient dans son verre, quelque chose comme ça.
Très très amoureuse, qui rentre pas, qui reste pas dans le rôle qu'on lui assigne de voilà d'épouse très qui s'occupe du ménage et tout ça.
Tu vois où je veux en venir ?
Non, pas du tout. Je vois que tu fais un regard comme si tu voulais que je saisisse la balle au bond, mais je vois pas où est la balle.
En fait, bah, non mais c'est clairement, c'est très certainement moi qui ai des biais partout. Mais quand on parle de gens qui aiment beaucoup les animaux, qui restent pas à leur place, qui sont très émotifs, qui...
Tu vois où je veux en venir ?
Ah les-- nos amis les autistes.
Moi, je l'ai vu comme ça en lisant. Mais c'est peut-être juste moi qui ai un énorme biais.
Bah alors clairement, ce personnage est bâti à partir de moi. Tu vois--
C'est pour ça que je parlais de parallèle avec--
Évidemment, mais c'est ça aussi que je montre, comment mes expériences nourrissent la création des personnages.
C'est ça.
Je bâtis Youri, donc le mari de Marina, mais je le dis dans le livre, je consacre un chapitre à ça pour montrer quelle est mon inspiration.
Alors je m'inspire bien sûr des choses lues, vécues, entendues, mais ça doit être nourri d'autres choses aussi. Le personnage doit commencer à vivre dans ta tête, sinon tu sais pas le décrire.
Et Marina, forcément, enfin, je vais me le-- Flaubert disait Madame Bovary, c'est moi. Et étant le Flaubert de Limelette.
Je plaisante évidemment hein, la team Flaubert. Non, mais voilà, Marina Schaffhaus c'est moi, mais c'est pas dans le sens où je suis moi aussi--
Oui, peut-être pas son vécu, son expérience, mais--
Une amazone couteau au poing, mais c'est moi parce que je la sors de moi. D'où voudriez-vous que je la sorte ?
C'est ça.
D'autres. Et ceux qui disent non, moi, mes livres, c'est vraiment de la pure imagination ou alors c'est du pur factuel.
Les deux, c'est complètement faux. C'est un mélange des deux quoi.
Donc à partir de cette logique-là, tous tes personnages femmes sont un peu autistes du coup.
Mmm. Quand je décide de mettre--
Et pourquoi est-ce que tu as décidé ici ?
Parce que alors je crois que quand-- donc ce dont on est sûr, c'est qu'un jour, elle s'est présentée aux nazis en disant : C'est moi la terroriste, mettez-moi en prison, tuez-moi, voilà, j'endosse la responsabilité
Pour faire ça, enfin, c'est très déraisonnable.
Mmm-hmm.
À tout point de vue.
On sort des règles implicites, on sort de ce qui est la norme sociale--
Tout à fait.
De ce qui est l'ordre, tout ça. On fait un truc--
Oui, on sort déjà de ce qui est attendu des mères, c'est-à-dire qu'elles n'abandonnent pas leurs enfants. Et on sort de ce qui est attendu aussi de la résistance.
Bon la résistance existait pas encore vraiment à l'époque, mais ça commençait un tout-- les gens commençaient un peu à grenouiller, à se parler, à se mettre en réseau.
Mais bon, c'était pas encore très très organisé. Mais s'il y avait un truc qu'on savait, c'est qu'on ne se rendait pas. Parce que si on se rendait, qu'on soit coupable ou non,
on risquait de balancer son réseau, on risquait de balancer les autres, on risquait de dire n'importe quoi.
Enfin, on mettait d'autres gens en danger quoi. Donc voilà, elle s'est rendue et elle s'est rendue sans retour en arrière possible.
Moi, je l'ai vu, je l'ai-- enfin, je l'ai lu dans la presse et dans ce qu'on a raconté d'elle.
Ce que l'aumônier qui l'a suivie jusque sur les chapeaux, pas vraiment un chapeau, mais l'estrade où elle a été mise à mort, disait,
qu'elle était satisfaite, que la décision était prise, qu'elle était ferme, qu'elle était satisfaite d'aller à la mort en fait, et qu'elle ne voulait pas d'une grâce.
Et y a un truc très entier, me semble-t-il, très idéaliste, très déraisonnable, et très transgressif.
Transgressif, ouais.
Et-- ouais, alors clairement, je vois très bien ce que tu veux dire en disant que ce sont peut-être des traits autistiques et peut-être les miens que j'ai--
Je vois ce que tu veux dire.
Voilà. Voilà. Je sais pas si les gens le verront, mais du moment que tu vois, moi ça me va.
All right. Et donc un autre aspect que tu présentes pour expliquer cette différence, c'est aussi sa tante--
Ouais.
Qui, elle aussi, est très différente.
Et une guerrière, une vieille guerrière. Comment est-ce que t'as travaillé aussi sur son histoire à elle ?
Oui, ben sa tante, elle s'appelait Nina Petrova et je suis tombée sur son histoire vraiment par hasard encore une fois,
parce que je cherchais des gens à rencontrer pour nourrir mon roman, des gens de la famille et enfin des descendances ou je sais pas quoi, de Marina.
Enfin voilà, j'obs-- j'explorais son arbre généalogique et je regarde celui de sa mère. Et puis je vois qu'une des sœurs de sa mère s'appelle Nina Petrova et qu'elle a une photo.
Enfin bref, je clique, je Google. Nina Petrova, en fait, était une snipeuse de légende, ce que j'ignorais bien sûr,
qui avait, elle, contrairement à Marina, une page Wikipédia à son nom, qui a reçu toutes les décorations possibles qui constituent, quand on les met ensemble, une sorte de camembert, du Trivial Pursuit,
enfin, l'amulette ultime
des guerrières de l'Armée rouge.
Et donc elle était-- en fait, c'était une grande sportive à la base et elle pratiquait le tir sportif pour son--
Pour le fun quoi.
Pour son plaisir. Et en fait, elle était tellement bonne qu'elle est devenue prof de tir.
Et puis les circonstances faisant, elle a enseigné le tir qui n'était plus sportif, mais c'était du tir de précision à la carabine pour les soldats de l'Armée rouge.
Et elle-même, comme elle était évidemment excellente et instructrice, elle s'est dit : « Ben, il faut que je-- moi-même j'aille sur le front ».
Sauf qu'on lui a dit non, notamment parce qu'elle était une femme, mais aussi parce qu'elle était âgée, en tout cas selon les standards de l'époque, puisqu'elle avait quarante-huit ans.
Ouais. À l'époque, ouais, je comprends que ce soit vieux, ouais.
Ouais. Et puis à un moment donné, on a eu besoin de tous les index disponibles sur les gâchettes et on l'a autorisée à prendre part à la guerre.
Et donc voilà, elle a tué plus de cent vingt, plus de cent vingt nazis. Donc elle est considérée comme étant une grande héroïne de la guerre en Russie.
Et peut-être, c'est l'hypothèse que j'émets pour savoir comment--
qu'est-ce qui a pris à Marina, si on suit l'idée que c'est bien elle qui est allée poignarder un nazi porte de Namur et que-- puisque une des versions dit que ce n'est pas elle, elle n'a fait qu'endosser la responsabilité des hommes.
Voilà. Qu'est-ce qui a pu bien-- quelle mouche a bien pu la piquer ? Je me dis que cette mouche, elle peut, je sais pas, elle se déposait dans l'histoire d'abord de Nina Petrova, parce que c'était un sacré role model quoi.
Ça montrait-- c'était une histoire proche de Marina qui montrait que les femmes pouvaient avoir aussi accès à la violence et à l'effort de guerre.
Donc je me dis que c'est peut-être pas étranger à son engagement.
Mmm. Et tu
tu expliques-- puisqu'on l'a pas dit, mais donc tu as sorti également en parallèle de ce livre un podcast chez-- à la RTBF, chez Typique,
où tu parles un peu des coulisses, de ton travail de recherche qui entourait le travail d'écriture de ce roman.
Et une des choses que tu expliques, je crois, dans-- pour le dernier épisode, c'est que ce genre d'histoires de snipeuses russes qui dégomment des nazis dans la rue sont souvent récupérées par les fachos, en fait.
Oui, oui. Et puis pas uniquement les fachos quoi, les gens qui, enfin, cette espèce de petit droitard mollasson quoi.
Ok, au sens large, ouais.
Non, non, parce que, ouais, la figure de la snipeuse, elle est souvent convoquée pour montrer à quel point nos féministes aujourd'hui seraient des ouin-ouins qui se plaignent pour un rien.
Alors que rappelez-vous, jadis, les femmes, elles appuyaient sur la gâchette. Et enfin, c'est souvent utilisé, cette figure, pour nier qu'il y a un besoin de
de réguler peut-être ce qui se passe dans l'espace public, ou de contraindre, ou de sanctionner des comportements d'agression ou de harcèlement de rue, etc.
Enfin voilà, elle ressort toujours, la snipeuse russe comme étant : « Eh ben elle au moins, elle se plaignait pas, elle faisait... »
Des mecs qui contraignent et qui expliquent très fortement quelle est la place et quel est le comportement que les femmes doivent avoir.
Et puis en même temps expliquent que : « Mais elles n'ont qu'à... » Elles n'ont qu'à être les snipeuses russes.
Exactement.
Voilà, bon voilà. Et donc-
C'est vraiment un red flag énorme, quand on voit quelqu'un glorifier les snipeuses russes sur les réseaux, je veux dire qu'a priori, c'est un gros con.
Mais donc, voilà, tu sors plusieurs éléments, donc un profil psychologique que tu ressens en lisant les lettres, en regardant son comportement au tribunal et ainsi de suite.
Un passif héréditaire-
Ouais.
Familial de cette tante.
Oui, hérédité symbolique puisque je pense que c'est-
Oui bien sûr.
Enfin voilà, un rôle modèle qui la précède et qui précède assez peu de femmes belges puisque y a pas vraiment de...
Voilà. Un rôle modèle familial, c'est ça que je voulais dire. Et quoi d'autre ? Quels sont les autres éléments qui permettent d'expliquer le fait que c'est quelqu'un qui sort dehors...
Alors, là dans le bouquin, je dépeins une série de petites humiliations qui sont de nature à mettre le feu aux poudres.
Mh.
Surtout familiales aussi.
Oui, une déception par rapport à l'air du temps aussi, le fait qu'elle ne soit pas dans son pays, que ce soit une exilée, je crois que ça peut être très--
les frustrations d'exilées, je crois, peuvent se transformer en quelque chose de relativement explosif.
Ouais.
Et je lui ai aussi prêté une sorte de trouble anxieux, enfin, qu'on appelle aujourd'hui un trouble anxieux, mais qu'à l'époque, on disait, je sais pas ce qu'on disait à l'époque, hystérie, non, j'en sais rien.
C'est certainement quelque chose de très condescendant, mais une mélancolie peut-être, voilà. Entre la mysté-
Ouais, l'hystérie et la mélancolie. C'est-- toute une série d'ingrédients en fait, mais c'est très difficile d'expliquer et de cérébraliser ce qui finalement m'est venu, comme ça m'est venu.
Ouais, très naturellement, très instinctivement finalement, ouais. Et donc,
un autre aspect intéressant, et tu l'as mentionné, c'est le fait que divinisée, quelque part mythifiée, admirée côté russe,
y compris donc très peu de temps après ta découverte aussi de Nadexa, il y a eu une cérémonie, je crois, au centre culturel russe de Belgique, c'est ça ?
Oui. Enfin une sorte de conférence quoi.
Ouais ouais. Et qu'est-ce qu'ils disent au sujet de Marina, les Russes ?
Oh, les Russes, ils en avaient une version qui a été portée à l'écran dans un film. Aussi, y a eu un livre.
Apparemment, les Russes voudraient,
refaire un film aujourd'hui, de nos jours. Je sais pas quel parti pris ils auraient là-dessus, mais oui, leur vision, c'est que c'était une grande héroïne soviétique, vraiment un padawan de Staline et un pur animal politique, en fait.
Patriotique.
Oui, c'est ça. Vraiment une femme déjà presque statufiée dans le marbre de son vivant. C'est ça que disaient les Russes.
Mais évidemment, moi, j'y crois pas du tout.
Oui. Et pourquoi tu n'y crois pas ?
Parce que je crois pas-- je crois qu'on a des raisons très pratiques et très personnelles de s'engager et qu'une-- un pur animal politique de naissance, je n'en connais pas en fait.
Surtout que si on est dans une logique patriotique, politique, de s'engager pour l'environnement qui nous a élevés et tout ça-
Ouais.
Une femme de l'époque resterait à une place très assignée, très ménagère et tout ça. Et pas...
Ouais. Alors, il se fait aussi-
C'est bizarre de se rebeller contre les règles du ménage et de la famille et tout ça, pour en même temps être très très droit dans les rangs, très patriotique et tout ça.
Ouais ouais, mais alors il se fait aussi que-- donc Marina est d'origine russe et que, en Russie, on pouvait voter depuis 1919, je pense.
Ouais ouais.
Ou enfin, ces années-là. Et la Révolution russe de 1917, c'est une révolution qui a été initiée, entre guillemets, par une révolte de femmes.
Mh.
Et si on descend dans la rue tous les huit mars pour dire qu'on en a marre d'être agressées, c'est parce que des Russes, le huit mars
1917, sont descendues dans les rues pour réclamer du pain, le retour de leurs maris, enfin toute une série de choses.
Mais voilà, c'était une révolte avant tout féministe. Donc le fait de venir d'un pays
qui n'a pas tout à fait le même rapport à la violence que nous, peut-être pas tout à fait le même rapport à la mystique, pas tout à fait le même rapport à la politique et à l'émancipation féminine, ça a certainement dû jouer dans le,
dans l'anomalie que représente Marina dans un paysage bruxellois où c'était vraiment pas légion que les femmes prennent part à ce genre de choses.
Et je pense que t'as raison d'avoir peur d'une récupération de-- s'ils refont un film dans le contexte politique actuel-
Oui.
Faut avoir très peur quoi.
Ben oui oui, quand on voit que Poutine essaye de raviver la nostalgie jamais vraiment enfouie de l'Armée rouge, de ses héros, de-- espèce de guerrier pur, et animé par uniquement l'amour de la patrie.
Enfin voilà, oui, c'est-- j'espère que ça se reproduira pas comme ça.
Lors de cette célébration, même, je sais pas comment on peut appeler ça, mais c'est cette cérémonie, cet événement au centre culturel russe en Belgique, il y avait aussi donc, si j'ai bien compris, son fils.
Oui.
Fils de Marina qui a pris la parole. J'ai oublié son prénom.
Vadim.
Vadim ? Oui, c'est ça. Et lui, justement, pas trop fan de la déification de sa maman.
Non.
Et tu l'as rencontré.
Oui oui oui. Oui, je l'ai rencontré plusieurs fois. Il est-- c'est assez ambivalent parce qu'il ressent beaucoup quand même d'affection pour cette femme.
C'est très étrange évidemment de voir un homme âgé de quatre-vingt-trois, quatre-vingt-quatre ans parler d'une mère.
Il avait trois ans et demi quand sa mère est morte. Enfin, il y a quelque chose de-- il appelle maman une femme de trente-trois ans.
Enfin, c'est ça qui me semble particulièrement à la fois beau et terriblement triste.
Qu'est-ce-- ah oui. Non, j'ai pas compris, en fait. Qu'est-ce qui est étrange ?
Qu'un homme âgé appelle une jeune femme de cinquante moins que lui, maman.
Oui, mais ça reste sa maman. Enfin, c'est pas...
Bien sûr.
Voilà.
Mais c'est quand même très étrange, non ? Cette superposition de-
Ça me choque pas, moi.
Ça ne me choque pas non plus. Je trouve ça juste joli.
Ça me-- OK. Oui oui, joli, oui. J'imagine.
Joli et inhabituel.
Inhabituel, je comprends.
Ouais, parce que les parents sont quand même censés...
Oui mourir-
Plus âgé.
C'est ça ouais.
J'ai l'impression que t'as peur de la vie.
Je changeant.
Et donc oui, Vadim, lui, il défend l'idée que sa mère était une femme ordinaire, mais ça, c'est un fil que j'ai tiré aussi hein.
Je pense que c'était une femme ordinaire et c'était pas une déesse quoi. C'est pas une héroïne.
Elle est pas née héroïne. Je pense que c'est l'embranchement, une succession de choses qui l'ont menée sur ce chemin.
C'est ça que j'essaie de raconter, la succession de choses. Mais donc lui, il a-- en fait, ce qu'il raconte, c'est que sa mère a existé autrement que comme une,
une héroïne et qu'il-- qu'elle a vécu, n'a pas fait que mourir dans sa vie, sa mère.
C'est vrai que parler toujours de sa mère sous la perspective de sa mort,
ça doit être relativement désagréable. Et lui, il pense que c'est pas sa mère qui a tué, enfin, qui a poignardé, parce qu'en l'occurrence, il en est pas mort, le nazi, le sept décembre 1941.
Lui, il pense que c'est son père, peut-être accompagné d'un autre homme, parce que c'était pour lui son père, la personne politisée du ménage, la personne, 'fin, et puis l'inconscient, le,
le mec pas cohérent, le fier à bras, un peu frimeur, qui se rend pas compte des conséquences de ses actes.
Lui, il estimait que sa mère était quelqu'un de très responsable et que quelqu'un de très responsable ne pouvait pas faire ce genre de choses.
Et puis qu'elle aimait ses enfants. Et ça, c'est vrai. Quand on lit ses lettres, c'est vraiment une femme qui adorait ses enfants et qui leur parlait à hauteur d'enfant.
C'est ça qui est aussi très beau dans, dans les lettres.
Et c'est une lecture très politisée de la chose, du coup, en se disant : c'est pas possible parce qu'elle était pas assez-- 'fin c'est une interprétation, c'est une déduction et plus qu'une certitude.
Mais lui, il a lu des trucs, il a entendu des trucs, il a aussi parlé avec la mère de Marina. Donc quand Marina était en prison, elle a eu la visite de sa mère, Ludmilla, et elle aurait dit à Ludmilla la vérité.
Et Ludmilla aurait répété la vérité qui serait que c'était Vadim, c'était Youri, pardon, le-
Son mari.
Son mari, le coupable. Et donc c'est ça la version que Vadim défend aujourd'hui et qui est une version qu'il n'est pas-- qui est tout à fait entendable.
Alors, il y a deux éléments qui vont très fort dans son sens. Je trouve, c'est le fait que vu que sa mère était une femme très petite.
Ça, il me l'a beaucoup dit, il l'a beaucoup répété.
Un mètre cinquante-six.
Oui, ça me semble pas si petit que ça pour ces années-là, mais voilà. Vu que tu fais six mètres, tu dois trouver ça extrêmement petit, mais bon.
Elle était très petite, assez menue et donc il estime que ce n'est pas possible qu'il ait pu-- elle ait pu administrer une plaie si profonde,
puisque la plaie faisait dix-huit centimètres de long, apparemment, enfin de profondeur, à un homme
adulte, avec une capote, 'fin avec un manteau en laine épais. Voilà.
Il y a aussi le fait que jamais il n'est mentionné sur les avis de recherche du coupable que c'était une femme ou une très petite personne, alors que si
c'était manifestement le trait vraiment saillant de son physique, je pense que tous les avis de recherche l'auraient dit.
Les avis de recherche étaient tous genrés au masculin aussi. Enfin, parce que voilà, c'est là qu'on se dit que peut-être qu'il...
Ou inversement, avis de recherche qui ne mentionnait qu'un seul-- une seule personne et pas deux comme sa version le sous-tend.
Oui, tout à fait. Ouais. Et donc ça, c'est clairement que-- 'fin voilà, ça, c'est des choses qui jouent en la faveur de sa version, 'fin de sa vision.
Par contre, ce qui va en sa défaveur, en tout cas selon moi, c'est qu'elle s'est domiciliée dans une chambre de bonne à quelques mètres du domicile familial, une semaine avant la commission de l'attentat.
Donc, elle prévoyait quelque chose.
Mh.
Maintenant, ça peut être tout et n'importe quoi. Ça peut être son mari qui l'a obligée à aller à la commune pour louer une-- ou ça peut être une coïncidence.
Peut-être qu'elle voulait quitter son foyer, mais en lisant les lettres, on se rend bien compte que c'est pas les lettres d'une femme qui s'apprêtait à quitter son foyer, son mari.
Donc, il y avait une entourloupe. Il y avait quelque chose qui, voilà. J'ai vu les papiers de la commune disant : « Changement de domicile, Marina Jafrov va habiter maintenant au trois, rue Kans, à Ixelles.
» Et p'tite soupente à quelques pas de là où elle habitait avec toute sa famille. Donc ça, pour moi, c'est vraiment le plus-- l'élément le plus en défaveur de la théorie de ce n'était pas elle derrière le couteau. Voilà.
Mh. Et en tout cas, ce qu'on-- le portrait qu'on lit dans ton livre et même dans la bouche de Vadim, du coup, c'est que son père était plutôt...
il vivait la vie avec légèreté. Il l'a décrit comme un lâche.
Ouais.
Du coup, c'est pas hyper compatible avec l'idée d'aller assassiner un officier nazi, je trouve.
Oui, si, je pense que ça peut. Ça peut prendre des décisions inconséquentes parce qu'on ne s'attend pas à devoir en assumer les conséquences.
Ça peut. Ça peut. Je trouve que c'est pas impossible hein.
Ok. Et qu'est-ce qui a fait que tu, donc face à ces différentes hypothèses probables, tu es resté,
pas tout à fait dans la version russe, pas non plus dans la version du fils, mais dans une version un peu,
entre les deux, entre guillemets, où elle au-- d'après toi, tu estimes qu'elle est probablement l'autrice de cet attentat,
mais qu'elle n'est pas hyper politisée.
'Fin qu'est-ce qui a fait que tu as choisi cette voie-là ? Et pas celle du fils.
C'est vraiment très difficile à dire. Je pense que j'ai fait la somme de ce qu'on m'a dit, la somme de ce que j'ai lu et que le personnage a choisi son propre chemin, en fait, et que
la voie médiane, c'est celle qui s'est imposée, mais j'ai peut-être totalement tort.
Et j'en sais rien. En fait, les seuls éléments de preuve dont on aurait pu disposer, c'est les minutes de son procès.
Sauf qu'on les a pas, puisque quand les Allemands ont quitté Bruxelles, ils ont incendié le palais de justice et que voilà, y a plus de-- c'était fini.
Enfin, tout ça a été réduit en cendres. Et donc on a que des versions, on a que du déclaratif. Et qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec ça ?
On fait des intuitions, quoi. Donc moi, mon intuition, c'est celle que je bâtis dans le livre et c'est celle que je décide de présenter à la fin du livre, mais en même temps, je change parfois d'avis.
Ouais.
Je suis pas sûre, mais quelque part, c'est un livre qui-- enfin, on s'en fout un peu, je trouve, de savoir est-ce que c'est elle qui a commis le premier attentat ou bien est-ce qu'elle n'a fait que se rendre.
Disons que c'est pas central à partir du moment où, comme tu dis, tu traites le sujet avec humilité en présentant le fait que t'es pas hyper sûre non plus de ta version, quoi.
Tu présentes le fait que tout est en question.
Oui, et puis bon, le but est aussi de montrer que l'histoire, c'est une notion un peu à géométrie variable quoi, et comme la vérité aussi.
Et y a la citation que je mets en exergue sur la première page du livre, c'est un internaute qui, sur Instagram, m'avait-- avait essayé de m'expliquer les théories de Walter Benjamin et m'avait dit un truc du style :
''L'histoire est une fiction qui cherche à expliquer le présent et en fonction du présent, le passé change.'' C'était, c'est ça.
Je comprends.
Et c'est ça, en fait, c'est tout le projet du livre. Enfin, il y a quelques citations dans le livre qui rappellent un peu le projet.
Donc, il y a ça : ''En fonction du présent, le passé change.'' C'est pour montrer un peu ce que c'est l'histoire, en fait.
Un point de vue situé, quoi.
Quand on s'y confronte, ouais. Et puis,
il y a aussi une citation de Valérie Solanas qui dit : ''Rien dans cette société ne concerne les femmes.'' Et être femme aujourd'hui, enfin, je sais plus exactement ce qu'elle dit, mais c'est, dans cette société, c'est au mieux y mourir d'ennui.
Alors dans le livre, je ne mets pas la fin de la citation, mais donc elle propose de mettre à sac l'ordre établi, de couper des bites et surtout de bien rigoler.
Mais comme le bien rigoler me semblait assez peu raccord avec la vie de Marina, j'ai retiré le, voilà, j'ai retiré le truc où elle nous invitait à vraiment se taper sur la cuisse.
Mais tout ça, pour moi, ça résume ce que je veux faire, quoi. Ce que j'ai voulu faire.
Ouais. Et, mais justement, cette notion de en fonction du présent, le passé change, ça, c'est ça qui m'a fatigué avec la version donc du fils, notamment.
Et aussi, le fait que, ça m'a beaucoup amusé, ça. Quand tu l'as rencontré, il t'a demandé : ''Est-ce que vous êtes féministe ?''
Ouais.
Pourquoi-- OK. Pourquoi il t'a demandé ça, à ton avis ?
Je sais pas.
Ouais.
Il a soupiré quand t'as répondu.
Oui. Non, je sais pas. Peut-être qu'il avait pas envie que je traite cette histoire en faisant de sa mère une héroïne féministe.
Une Jeanne d'Arc.
Oui, c'est ça. Mais en fait, j'ai pas fait de sa mère une héroïne. Enfin, quelque part, ses actes, c'est une manière d'affirmation de soi qui, quelque part, raconte une histoire féministe.
Son histoire raconte quelque chose de féministe. Mais elle, j'en sais rien. Et probablement pas. Probablement parce que c'était, je sais pas, que féministe à l'époque, je suis même pas sûre que le mot existait vraiment.
Et à mon avis, il devait être plus ou moins synonyme de lépreuse. Enfin... Et alors, parce que donc le film soviétique qui est sorti sur Marina la montre, elle, vraiment, rentrer en clandestinité.
Et d'ailleurs, elle met un gros bonnet et un gros pull mal tricoté, ce qui est vraiment le signe de l'entrée en clandestinité dans les films de cette époque-là.
Et elle est prise dans des fusillades. Enfin, c'est vraiment, c'est Indiana Jones quoi. Et puis à la fin, déjà, elle se rebiffe contre l'occupant parce que son mari meurt dans une fusillade, il se prend une balle perdue.
Donc enfin, c'est très bizarre qu'un film politique soviétique montre une femme se rebeller contre les nazis uniquement par douleur de perdre son mari et pas par engagement politique, mais enfin, soit.
Et la montre, non pas avec un couteau à la main, mais avec un petit flingue et buter un gros légume nazi. Ce qui était pas le cas, hein, dans la vérité.
C'était, je pense, un Oberinspektor Kattenhorn. Personne sait qui c'est, il a pas du tout marqué l'histoire. C'était pas un haut dignitaire, mais dans le film soviétique, c'est un haut dignitaire qu'elle bute.
Encore une fois, en fonction du présent, le passé change.
Oui, c'est ça.
On a envie de dramatiser, on a envie de donner de l'importance à cette personne russe qui a tué un gars.
Et dans le film, le dignitaire nazi meurt alors que dans la réalité, il est pas mort. L'homme a réchappé de ses blessures.
Mais tout ça pour dire qu'il faut voir... vous le trouvez. Si vous tapez quelque part Quelque part un loriot pleure, qui est le nom de ce film, vous le traduisez en cyrillique avec Google Traduction ou j'en sais rien.
Et puis vous tapez vidéo dans votre onglet Google et vous allez tomber sur ce film. Vous n'allez rien comprendre si vous ne parlez pas russe, mais
c'est vraiment très marrant quoi, parce qu'on dirait un téléfilm érotique, y a des scènes de douche où ils font du-- elle et son mari, du frotti-frotta sur la douche et puis-- sous la douche.
Et puis la manière dont meurt le nazi qu'elle tue avec son petit fusil, c'est un milliard de fois encore plus marrant en plus que Marion Cotillard qui meurt dans Batman quoi.
Je veux dire, c'est vraiment la mort la plus nulle de l'histoire du cinéma. Donc voilà, je vous invite à aller voir ça, c'est spectaculaire.
Magnifique.
Mais donc voilà, tout ça pour dire que j'en avais parlé à Vadim de ce film et il le connaissait, mais alors lui, ça l'a fait rire.
Il a éclaté de rire quand je lui ai parlé-
Tu lui as parlé de la scène.
Oui, quand je lui ai parlé du-- enfin, parce que pour lui, ça, c'est vraiment du grand guignol, c'est pas la vérité.
Et je crois qu'il a vraiment raison. C'est du grand guignol, ouais.
Et donc, puisqu'on parle de la famille, de la descendance de Marina, je crois savoir que tu étais contactée hier ou avant-hier par l'arrière-
Ouais
...petite-fille de Marina. Qu'est-ce que t'as pu échanger avec elle ?
Deux arrière-petites-filles de Marina.
Deux arrière-petites-
Et aussi un petit-fils d'un frère de Marina qui m'a contactée.
Ok.
Voilà. Et donc, ils n'ont pas encore lu le livre. Il y en a une qui a commencé le podcast et qui dit que ça lui plaît plutôt.
Et en tout cas, les petites-filles à qui j'ai vraiment un petit peu plus parlé semblent être extrêmement fières du-
Oh cool
...devenir d'une femme pareille. Et je comprends. Je trouve ça vraiment classe, moi aussi. Et elles avaient l'air heureuses qu'on,
qu'à l'occasion du livre, ça ravive son souvenir et que ça porte son histoire à la connaissance d'un plus grand nombre. Donc-
Ok
...c'est vraiment super chouette.
Espérons qu'elles gardent cet avis une fois qu'elles auront lu.
Ah non, tu crois pas ? Faut qu'elles réfléchissent.
Mais je dis, mais je dis. Tu dis qu'elles n'ont pas encore lu le livre.
Non, non. Ouais.
Voilà. Espérons qu'elles gardent cet avis.
Oui.
Et ben, à propos de, donc, lecture du livre, qu'est-ce que--
est-ce que t'as un espoir pour-- parce que tu as parlé des différents messages que tu voulais faire passer à travers le livre, notamment, donc, citation que j'aime beaucoup aussi, en fonction du passé.
Oh, mais moi, je veux faire passer aucun message dans ce livre. Je veux juste raconter une histoire qui fait des constats.
Non, mais tu dis ça, mais tu viens d'expliquer que tu t'aimais beaucoup et tu voulais mettre en avant cette notion de : en fonction du présent, le passé change.
Ah non, non. Pour moi, c'est un peu comme un-- c'est une sorte de table des matières du livre. C'est tout. C'est-
Ok
...ces phrases-là, elles racontent, elles résument en hyper condensé-
Mmh mmh
...ce qui vient ensuite. Mais c'est pas, je n'ai pas envie de crier : « Voilà, c'est ça que je veux dire ».
Parce qu'en fait, moi, je crois que j'avais juste envie de donner une sépulture décente-
Ok
...et un peu plus rutilante à une femme que je trouve dommage de pas, voilà, d'avoir oubliée à ce point. Et montrer qu'on est tous liés, que l'histoire, c'est pas du passé, et euh...
Il y a quand même un projet. Il y a quand même un-
Il y a un projet, mais il y a pas un message. Il y a pas-
D'accord
...un soyez gentil avec les papillons.
Il y a pas de récupération. Ok, ouais. Mais-
Ah si. Ben oui. Si, bien sûr qu'il y a une récupération, parce que cette histoire, moi, elle est de nature aussi, c'est sans doute pour ça que je l'ai choisie aussi.
Elle est de nature à servir mon agenda féministe. Voilà.
Féminazi.
Oui. Ah ben non, je pense que c'est très mal venu, féminazi, dans ce contexte.
Je crois aussi. Ok. Et, mais, donc, mais dis, dis m'en plus là-dessus. Qu'est-ce que, est-ce que...
Mais non, mais évidemment que moi, je vais choisir des histoires qui racontent à quel point on a été cancellés de l'histoire-
Mmh mmh
...ou à quel point les choses ne se sont pas passées comme elles auraient dû. Donc, oui, cette histoire, elle sert à ça aussi, mais c'est pas, il y a pas de message en particulier quoi.
C'est une sélection. Ça m'intéresse pour ça, pour cette raison-là aussi quoi. Je pense que si ça avait été un mec cancellé, ça m'aurait pas-
Oui, c'est ça
...ça m'aurait pas plus intéressée que ça.
Non. Et du coup, ton intérêt spécifique pour la Deuxième Guerre mondiale, maintenant, il est clôturé ou bien tu vas chercher d'autres résistantes décapitées à explorer, à mettre en avant ?
Bah alors, bon, dans le cadre d'un bouquin, je pense que je vais un peu me renouveler, changer de registre après, parce que sinon, je pense que je vais...
Enfin, j'ai pas envie de faire tout le temps la même chose, mais je passe quand même encore un temps considérable dans les archives de la presse-
C'était ma question
...KBR. C'est dingue. Je sais pas si t'es déjà allé faire des-
Non
...des tours là-dedans.
Oh, c'est passionnant, c'est fou. C'est-- je perds mon temps à taper le nom de gens. Quand je rencontre quelqu'un, je tape son nom de famille et tout, je me dis : « Tiens, je vais voir s'il avait un grand-père collabo. »
T'as déjà eu des découvertes marrantes en faisant ça ou c'est juste perte de temps ?
Oui, non. Ben, j'ai mon amie Justine qui a découvert que son grand-père avait tué quelqu'un.
Ok.
Bon, par accident, mais voilà, oui, il a renversé, enfin, il a écrasé, non, il a propulsé dans les airs un cycliste qui s'est empalé sur un panneau de signalisation.
Ok. Mais donc rien à voir avec les nazis.
Non, non. Mais en tout cas, beaucoup à voir avec sa vie parce qu'elle s'est dit : « Ben oui, c'est vrai que mon grand-père, c'était un drôle de type qui était très dépressif, très affecté.
» Et donc ça s'était produit, évidemment avant sa naissance. C'était une histoire qu'on racontait pas trop dans la famille quoi. Il y a,
avec certains potes, on a découvert, mais c'est des petits trucs, mais c'est-- enfin, que leurs grands-parents
avaient fait un peu de prison pour avoir volé un tapis, par exemple, ou un grille-pain, avoir fait du recel de grille-pain.
Il y a plein de trucs. L'autre jour, par exemple, je sais plus, à l'occasion de l'expo Johnny Hallyday, j'ai tapé le nom du père de Johnny Hallyday.
Ok.
Oui, je m'embête un peu.
Why not ?
Et j'ai découvert, ce que j'ignorais, c'est que le père de Johnny Hallyday, en fait, était un,
un mec assez connu à Bruxelles qui avait ouvert un cabaret qui s'appelait, enfin, Le Rayon vert, je crois, un truc du genre, et où allaient se produire des tas de célébrités de l'époque.
Enfin, c'était pas rien quoi. Jean-Philippe Smet, il vient pas du fond d'un cabas douche quoi. C'est quand même un-- voilà, son père était-- enfin, c'était un théâtre cabaret assez prestigieux.
Et donc, je pouvais voir la programmation, en fait, de tous ces...
Ok, mais donc t'as vraiment une passion sans limites pour remonter l'histoire, regarder les ancêtres de telle et telle personne, de son entourage, des célébrités.
Oui, oui.
Ça-- et donc ça, ça ne s'arrête pas.
Non.
Ça a commencé avec Marina et ça ne s'est toujours pas arrêté.
Non, mais ça a commencé même un peu avant Marina. Enfin, de naissance, moi, j'ai toujours adoré la presse vintage.
Ok.
Mais que ce soit les Semaines de Suzette de ma grand-mère des années 20, j'ai grandi en lisant la Semaine de Suzette qui sont les publications les plus sexistes du monde.
Enfin, je veux dire, c'est dans la Semaine de Suzette que Bécassine est née. Bécassine qui n'a pas de bouche.
Parce que pourquoi parlerait-elle, Bécassine ? Elle n'est qu'une humble servante.
Right.
Et... Enfin, j'ai toujours adoré en fait les publications. Enfin, je sais pas si tu te retournes, tu peux voir ma bibliothèque, mais il y a Mademoiselle Age Tendre.
J'ai des compilations de Mademoiselle Age Tendre qui sont des magazines pour jeunes filles des années cinquante, soixante où c'est en fait le programme pour être une bonne jeune fille.
Et d'ailleurs, j'en parle aussi dans le livre parce que je suis tombée sur les publications que Marina voulait lire en prison et les magazines qu'elle voulait lire s'appelaient Bonne soirée.
Par hasard, quelques jours après que je découvre ça, je tombe sur une pile de Bonne soirée dans une brocante et je lis ces Bonnes soirées.
Et c'est que des histoires d'amour, de-- enfin, insultant, de passage, qui séduit. Nan, nan, nan. C'est que des histoires-
Un peu des contes de fées quoi, un peu de...
Ouais, mais où on dit toujours-- écrites par des hommes, des histoires écrites par des hommes. Des histoires dans un magazine qui a été créé par un-- enfin, Dupuis, qui est à l'initiative d'un chanoine catholique.
'Fin voilà. Donc l'idée était de proposer un cadre quand même relativement étriqué à l'imaginaire féminin. Et ce cadre devait-- 'fin, leur imaginaire pouvait s'exercer à l'intérieur de l'espace domestique et l'espace marital quoi.
Mais moi, j'ai toujours adoré-
Plutôt passif et plutôt-
Oui, c'est ça.
À qui il arrive des choses, mais qui ne sont pas vraiment agentes de leur histoire quoi.
Oui, exactement.
Ok.
Et j'ai toujours collectionné en fait ce genre de publications. J'adore les manuels pour jeunes filles. Ça m'éclate.
Ça t'amuse ?
Oui, ça m'amuse.
C'est drôle parce que c'est ridicule quoi.
Oui, bon, peut-être que... C'est tellement désuet. J'adore aussi les vieilles pubs qui nous prennent vraiment pour des quiches.
Mmh.
Et qui dit : ''Madame, bien sûr que vous n'avez pas de mari puisque vos pores sont obstrués. Utilisez donc le savon Lux grâce auquel les hommes se battront pour vous demander en mariage.'' Et alors, on voit un avant-après, mais dessiné.
On voit un nez plein de points noirs dessinés. Et puis à droite-
Photoshop.
Oui, mais c'est génial. Moi, j'adore. Et tous les arguments marketing, mais complètement cons, qu'on nous sort pour nous vendre n'importe quoi, des gélules de céleri pour guérir du diabète, de l'obésité, des varices et de la mauvaise haleine.
'Fin voilà. Donc tout ça, ça reste un intérêt spécifique quand même très très obsédant. Donc je continue à creuser le sujet.
Que j'ignorais.
Mais pour le plaisir.
Ouais, ouais, c'est ça. Tu vas pas-- a priori, t'as pas un autre projet dans ce registre ?
Je sais pas, parce qu'en plus, tout à l'heure, je voyais Laurence Bibot qui va bientôt se lancer dans un spectacle issu de playbacks qu'elle fait sur des vidéos de la Sonuma, donc de la télé hyper vintage,
'fin des années cinquante, soixante, septante, quatre-vingt, parfois nonante.
Mais voilà, elle incarne des femmes, elle refait en fait le lip-ping de femmes marrantes ou extravagantes ou tournées en ridicule.
Enfin, soit. Et je me disais, mais moi, j'aimerais bien aussi faire ça avec des trucs— parce que c'est un peu la même logique quoi.
C'est aussi le ''on nous prend pour des quiches'' un peu. Ça amuse Laurence, elle en fait des playbacks, elle en fait un spectacle.
Moi, le ''on nous prend pour des quiches'', ça m'amuse et je trouve qu'il y a certainement un truc rigolo à faire avec ça.
Et je ne ferme pas la porte à l'idée de faire—
Une espèce de BD style infographiste ou un truc comme ça ?
Ça pourrait, oui, ça pourrait.
Ouais.
Mais en fait, il y a même pas besoin. Il y a même pas besoin pour être marrant de—
Ah, ça pourrait être une compile.
D'intervenir dessus. Oui, on peut juste les choisir et les mettre bout à bout.
Mais donc, toujours dans cette logique de ton enquête, remonter l'histoire et tout ça. Tu m'avais expliqué il y a un an que tu étais tombée par hasard, je crois, sur un journaliste—
Qui m'a dit alors que j'allais clôturer le texte en fait, et bientôt l'envoyer à ma maison d'édition, qui m'a dit : Ah ouais, on m'a dit que tu travaillais sur Marina Schiaffro.
Ah bah allez, c'est incroyable. Tu sais que j'en ai encore parlé hier soir au dîner. Je dis : Bah non, je ne savais pas.
Non mais, mais alors, tu sais cette histoire ? Non, mais c'est parce que ma belle-mère a été mariée avec un homme qui était très ami avec les frères de Marina à une époque, avec le mari de Marina.
Mais donc, tu sais, la fameuse rumeur. Je dis : Bah non, je sais pas quoi. Et que Marina était enceinte au moment de mourir.
Je dis : Non, jamais entendu parler. Et donc j'ai été rencontrer cette fameuse,
cette fameuse dame qui n'avait jamais connu Marina, forcément, mais qui avait— voilà, c'est ce mari, feu son mari, qui était beaucoup plus âgé, donc qui avait connu des contemporains de Marina.
Mais elle ne pouvait pas m'en dire plus. Donc c'était peut-être simplement une rumeur, encore une. Mais à quoi servait cette rumeur ?
Je ne sais pas. J'ai jamais vraiment bien su comment la décrypter, cette rumeur. Enfin, voilà.
Ok. Mais donc ça t'a amenée à rencontrer quelqu'un.
Mmh.
Tu veux nous en parler ?
Pourquoi ?
Parce que c'est super drôle comme histoire.
Ah oui. Oui, oui, non, mais c'était une dame— ouais, je le raconte dans— mais une dame incroyablement séduisante en fait.
D'un certain âge, je dirais une septantaine d'années, mais une— 'fin russe quoi, avec tout ce que ça peut avoir de très séduisant.
Exotique.
Aristo, oui, c'est ça. Très gracieuse, très drôle, très vive. Et puis bon, je lui explique mon projet. Elle me sert le thé avec infiniment de grâce.
Et je lui dis— elle veut absolument me donner des spéculoos que je mange parce qu'elle trouve que j'en prends plus, mais...
Voilà. Et je lui dis : Non, non, non. Mais parce qu'en plus, à l'époque, j'avais vraiment un régime hyper strict où dès que je mangeais un truc sucré, je faisais une dépression, une crise d'angoisse.
Et c'était un peu aussi ce que j'essayais de
d'exploiter dans le roman, c'est de montrer comment des angoisses intimes, 'fin dans ton
corps peuvent aussi donner lieu à des révoltes éventuellement politiques qui ne se seraient peut-être pas exprimées de cette manière-là si tu t'étais pas senti fondamentalement mal.
Enfin soit, je parle à cette inconnue de ma nature anxieuse et elle me dit que c'est le diable, c'est le diable
qui veut prendre possession de moi et que le diable, je dois me— elle me propose un auto-exorcisme
où il suffit de mettre ses doigts en pied de nez et de rire, rire absolument pour faire fuir le diable qui essaye de prendre possession de moi.
Je peux te dire que franchement, je suis restée—
Un pied de nez, tu peux montrer à la caméra ?
Alors un pied de nez, c'est ce truc-là, enfin manifestement, qu'on devait faire beaucoup dans les ''Ah na na, elle est amoureuse.
Ah il a un petit, un gros, un bouton'' 'fin.
C'est ça. Comme dans Tintin quoi.
Exactement.
Le truc avec le capitaine Haddock.
Voilà tout à fait. Et donc c'était—
Elle voulait t'exorciser avec son pied de nez.
En tout cas m'inviter à me montrer la solution à tous mes problèmes. Alors je n'ai pas vraiment essayé de mettre mes doigts comme ça lorsqu'une crise d'angoisse surgissait,
mais ce qui est intéressant, c'est qu'elle me disait que de par son expérience, tout dans la vie est une question de décision.
Donc voilà, c'est à méditer. Et la dépression et l'angoisse aussi. Et par conséquent la joie. Donc voilà, il faut que j'essaie d'implémenter ça dans ma vie.
Mais je rapporte surtout cette scène pour pouvoir
raconter la toute dernière scène du livre et montrer comment je l'invente cette scène et d'où je la sors, c'est-à-dire— enfin, je vais pas spoiler le truc, mais la dernière scène, c'est ma décision.
Je décide de la manière dont Marina s'est comportée et je raconte comment est-ce qu'elle va poignarder son nazi et cette espèce de pied de nez et de décision qu'elle prend et de décision sans recul possible.
On pourrait clôturer là-dessus, mais il reste cinq minutes.
Ah.
Donc on va parler de tes futurs projets. Qu'est-ce que tu as dans ta manche ? Qu'est-ce qu'il te—
Pas grand-chose.
Alors, tu avais un projet de roman pour lequel tu étais financée par la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles.
Oui, arrête de le rappeler, arrête de le leur rappeler parce que je ne l'ai pas rendu.
Mais je crois comprendre que tu— il est arrivé quelque chose, il est arrivé quelque chose à ton MacBook ?
Tout à fait. Tout à fait. Donc il me reste plus beaucoup de choses. Mon MacBook vient de me repéter dans les mains. Donc demain, je dois aller le reporter à l'Apple Store.
Enfin, c'est vraiment de la merde, ces Mac. Des Mac achetés en 2018, vraiment du caca.
Mais je vais m'y remettre, clairement, dans cette histoire de femme autiste confrontée aux exigences de la société et à une grossesse dont elle ne veut pas.
Je vais le faire, Guillaume, je te promets. En plus, je dois le faire puisqu'en effet, j'ai remporté une bourse pour amener ce projet à bien.
Donc, je suis obligée, sinon je vais devoir rembourser tout cet argent. Donc oui, il y a ça, mais c'est surtout un projet de série que je suis en train d'écrire en ce moment qui—
Avec Charlotte ? Charlotte Belier qui—
Tout à fait, qui était une de tes invitées.
Tout à fait.
Qui a mis sa carrière de professeure de français langue étrangère auprès des jeunes primo-arrivants, entre parenthèses, le temps d'écrire avec moi cette série.
Et, mais on peut être débranché à tout moment hein. Si ça se trouve,
la prochaine fois qu'on se verra, ce sera débranché parce que la RTBF et la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles qui cofinancent, en tout— et en tout cas la RTBF qui diffuse, voilà, il y a plein d'étapes.
Oui, elle peut changer d'avis en fonction de ce qu'on lui remet. Donc voilà, pour l'instant, je suis là-dessus. Je croise vraiment les doigts pour que ça aille jusqu'au bout parce que c'est un super projet et dont je suis hyper contente.
Je suis hyper gaie de travailler là-dessus. C'est une série sur l'école, mais du point de vue des profs. Et j'apprends un nouveau métier : scénariste et scénariste de série qui est encore très différent quoi.
J'adore ça, mais c'est très ingrat, c'est très long, c'est très, très fourmi, c'est très gai. Puis voilà, je pense que c'est vraiment le gros truc que j'ai sur le feu pour l'instant.
C'est à peu près tout.
Tu viens de sortir un livre, tu viens de sortir un podcast, tu travailles sur une série.
Ouais. Je travaille sur un scénario de film aussi.
Oui.
Mais ça, c'est pour moi. Enfin, personne me l'a commandé, mais c'est voilà, quand j'ai un peu de temps,
j'essaie de le poursuivre, mais c'est pas simple parce que je me suis lancée dans une histoire de science-fiction avec des voyages temporels et...
All right.
Oui. Et comme j'ai pas beaucoup de culture de la science-fiction, j'ai ni lu ni regardé beaucoup de choses.
Han han.
C'est des mécanismes que j'ai pas forcément, 'fin voilà.
Ok.
Je crois avoir fait des grandes trouvailles, en fait non, c'est...
Ah ouais ? Genre, qu'est-ce que t'as cru inventer puis finalement, tu t'es rendu compte que...
Non non, c'était même pas ça, mais c'est parce que moi, j'ai besoin de la faire voyager dans le temps, mon héroïne. Et je me suis dit ben, quand elle prend un Xanax, elle voyage dans le temps, voilà.
C'est nul, tu vois, il faut trouver un dispositif beaucoup plus chouette que ça. Donc, je suis en train
d'essayer de trouver une manière quand même beaucoup plus sympa et symboliquement intéressante que de la faire voyager dans le temps, tout ça parce qu'elle est un peu groggy par l'absorption du Xanax.
All right. Merci beaucoup Myriam.
Avec plaisir.
On arrive au bout de ces septante minutes et on se retrouve bientôt. Salut.
Ciao.
C'est déjà tout pour ce premier épisode de 2023. Je vous réserve quelques surprises dans les mois qui viennent que je ne vais pas vous révéler tout de suite, mais je peux quand même vous dire que le nouveau site web est presque, presque prêt
et qu'il va être super beau.
Pour ne rien manquer, n'oubliez surtout pas de suivre Septante Minutes Avec sur les réseaux sociaux. Tous les liens sont en description et n'oubliez pas de vous abonner au podcast sur votre plateforme de podcast préférée.
Il y a plein, plein, plein, plein, plein d'épisodes dans le catalogue avec des Alice Coffin, des Alexander De Croo, des Jean-Marc Jancovici, des Rokhaya Diallo, des Elisa Rojas, des Charlotte Belier, des Florence Hainaut, tout ça, tout ça, tout ça.
Je vous souhaite encore mes meilleurs vœux et je vous dis à très bientôt. Bisous.